RTO return to office is RTO Awards a war
over what should I do with my smaller
company I'm trying to attract people to
it I'm up to about 10 employees so I
said look the first thing if you've got
10 employees and you're trying to get
together and you're trying to build a
company building your culture building
together seems to be pretty important
and if you're actually interviewing
somebody that wants to you know work
from home or doesn't want to come in
then you're not talking to people that
are going to be committed to come in to
understand you understand your vision
I'm thinking about it if I was coming to
work for you I'd want to be right next
to you I want to know your vision what
you're doing I want to be one of your
main people I want to get there so the
question that people are asking there
I'm like unless you're in a market where
you're just absolutely can't find
anybody then I would be incredibly
reluctant on work from home for a
startup